okay hi everyone so a very great
thursday evening to all of you
and welcome to making measuring and
moving designing doing uncertainty
so i'm daryl and thank you so much for
joining us on this thursday evening
and we're so privileged to hear from our
three creators
or for from creators of three of our
very wonderful projects today before we
move on to a very short session of
a question and answer so you know
throughout the whole session please get
your questions ready and we'd love to
hear from you at the same time
so this event is organized by the design
singapore associates network and the
design singapore council
supported by the national design center
so this event is also part of the
national design center's
next-gen program which stretches all the
way from october
to november 2020. so this is the rough
kind of run-through of uh what's
happening today
so uh you know i'm just going to start
off with a very quick introduction to
what the design singapore associates
network is
before we hear from our uh the speakers
of our three projects
so firstly uh i'm part of the
design singapore associates network also
known as dan
so we're a group of designers you know
and we come from all different
different fields of design and we
believe in the good that design can do
so we love working with others to create
different kinds of platform to showcase
good design
especially design you know that's um
that has a certain particular purpose
so right now i would just like to share
with you about play
tomorrow's tropical cities so this is an
exhibition that's happening
at the national design center so i hope
some of you have had the chance to visit
it already
and you know for those of you who
haven't it's on until the end of the
month
so this project you know started um also
because of covet so during this time you
know during these troubling times
we think about how important play is you
know when we're stressed when there are
all these kind of uh
when there are different kinds of
challenges along the way
we always feel that play becomes more
important
and more and really so crucial to our
everyday lives
so it helps us look at things from
different angles as we read that
constantly almost like a game we're
always finding different ways to
approach
uh the challenges that we face and what
we want to show is that it's not just
about you know play being something that
uh happens when you're a child
but also that you know play happens in
all facets of our lives
from um from a work from the spaces
around us and how this can be turned
into a playground of sorts
so throughout the the kinds of work we
do we also ran two different exhibitions
last year
so this is called the future of craft
food and it looks at
our local hawker food through the lens
of design so you know how you know
different designers have interpreted
interpreted our basic dishes and how you
know it's
so wonderful to see what different
designers and how we see them
and we also had this other exhibition
called never too old which looked at
picture books and the power of
storytelling
and how you know just like the title
you're never too old because you know
picture books and stories
uh are so unique and so
special that you know everyone benefits
everyone can learn and
we really do learn so much from all of
these
so some of the other events we do you
know like what you're attending right
now
so we have a studio on the top of the
national design center and on the roof
you know we have a different sharing
sessions
talking about you know how design
impacts all of us
and also you know in different areas
like healthcare and we also run certain
other events like portfolio clinic
that you know links established
designers with
students with you know young designers
are looking to break into the view
so we're really glad that you know today
we have a lineup of very meaningful
projects
and you know i'm really uh
excited to share to introduce all of
them to you
so you know i just want to start off by
saying you know 2020 has been a very
very strange year indeed
so uncertainty is very much a theme of
everything that's been happening so far
we've learned how to redefine work
we found different ways of coping with
the challenges and you know
just how we're going to survive in the
midst of all this so as
i'm sure many of you have observed we
all react very differently
and personally it's been a very big
challenge so i think one thing that i've
learned is you know how to be a bit more
aware of
uh the struggles i'm going through and
also how to care for myself
but i feel that you know in the midst of
all this we must also be
you know extremely aware of how i
actually be aware
of how we can help others and especially
you know those of us who are involved in
the great inventory what our role is
during these times so i want to
introduce our first speaker danielle
who's going to be sharing you a little
bit more about making meaning
so this is a wonderful project that's a
ground-up community initiative
we bring it brings creatives and
non-profits together
as they volunteer their talents and how
they kind of
bring some amazing projects to life so
let me pass the time over to danelle
okay um hi everyone um
i'm danelle from making meaning a
platform that connects non-profits with
volunteer creatives
so i'm not sure how many of you have
heard of making meaning before
but in today's sharing i'd like to bring
you on a journey of
why and how i started making meaning and
the impact it's actually made on the
community so far
okay so when the circuit breaker started
and everyone began working remotely from
home for the first time
it was actually a very stressful period
for most of the creative community
i work at a branding consultancy called
somewhere else
and when businesses began to falter many
of them actually cut their design
budgets or cancelled events that we were
working on
and we suddenly found ourselves with
much less work than we usually had
so between working together to find new
work and
reinventing the services we're offering
to be more relevant
we actually had pockets of time that
needed to be filled
and so what we did was to keep ourselves
occupied
was to brainstorm new ideas and
resources to help the rest of the
creative community
so here are some of the things we came
up with at first
a cheat sheet for designers who are
looking to make their portfolio stand
out during interviews
a list of free and fun resources like
virtual studio tours and useful talks
for creative stuff at home and even
worksheets to teach your kids
design thinking and problem solving
while you're busy working
so while stuck at home i also found
myself reading much more news than usual
to keep updated i began following all
the news outlets
on telegram you know to see all the
latest developments on kobe 19.
and the topic of charities having
significant drops in donations as well
as other issues like migrant worker
rights kept cropping up yeah it was
really saddening but
at the same time pay cuts and needing to
support my family made it really tough
for me to donate as much as i wanted to
so when the government actually gave out
the 600 solidarity payout
it was a perfect opportunity to give
back so many fellow creatives like
um tyrion who runs the account the way
and well
actually urged the community to help out
and i was actually really moved by the
amount of support that
you know the rest of the creative
community gave
so it was around this time that i also
chanced upon
this very lovely campaign called home
for all
by the collective of migrant efforts
that was illustrated and designed by
ned and jackie from eight eight spot
it received so much traction and they
actually exceeded their goal raising
close to a million dollars which is
quite amazing when you think about it
because of this campaign i really
started to think about how design can
make an impact
and at the end of the day fundraising is
all about communicating a story
and a need in a way that touches the
hearts of others which is exactly the
role of design
so after donating my 600 to various
organizations
i continued to donate at first but after
a while it was
quite a strain on my personal finances
and i realized it wasn't feasible
to you know keep donating that amount
each month despite
my best intentions if you look at this
slide in an industry survey
done by don't mind if many other
creatives also struggled financially
with a loss of income
salary cuts and difficulty finding a job
so this really pushed me to think about
donating in a different way
if i can't donate money how else can i
give back
you know could design help non-profits
raise awareness and make more money
instead
so that's actually how i started making
meaning
for non-profits you know they have so
many things to worry about
least of all design so i knew it'd
really be a bit of an uphill battle
to convince them of its value but i felt
that
you know it really had the potential to
increase outreach and visibility for
them
in a world where branding is so
important and so powerful
so how the site works is that it's
simply a website
that functions like a job board so you
can click on available projects
and there's a list that you can explore
so volunteer roles are actually on an ad
hoc basis
so creatives can ask questions and you
know check out the timelines to ensure
that it's something they can
commit to i actually set this site up
and did all the copy and illustrations
in about a week and a half
so that i wouldn't end up sitting on it
for a long time
yeah when i first launched the site i
actually posted about it on reddit for
feedback
which meant that i got quite a few
cynical viewpoints on it
people commented on how you know
volunteering design services
was a really bad idea and they actually
incinerated that
offering skilled work pro bono was
equivalent to devaluing the design
profession
they cited many instances where you know
non-profits
or any organization could be very
demanding
especially when they're not paying cash
for the services they got
so these were all very valid points and
i did feel a bit discouraged when i read
all of the comments
i thought to myself you know did i make
a mistake
but when i thought about it more i
realized that pro bono design
is not the same as free design or
designing for exposure
in the same way a chef volunteers his
skills to cook for the needy
our driver transports food for the
underprivileged
giving your design skills for a course
that you know you care about
is no different so what really matters
is
how you approach the project so that
your non-profit
values the services you are giving so
that's why beyond a simple job board
making meaning became much more
it became a platform for education for
both creatives and non-profits
addressing misconceptions and teaching
both sides to set boundaries when
working on projects
i started off quite simply so actually
just creating guidelines and putting
them in place
to protect both parties so as to avoid
misunderstandings
and you know things like excessive
changes further down the line
for creatives i wanted them to really
value their work
and understand that you know when you
choose to offer
pro bono for a course that you care
about
it's an amazing thing to do and you
should never feel bad about it
or let someone else make you feel bad
about your choice to do that
yeah for non-profits
i realized that many of them actually
knew very little about creative world
and the impact it can make in fact most
of them
didn't even know how to write a creative
brain so when they first started writing
project briefs it would just be you know
one sentence like i want a poster
yeah so when you don't know why
something is so important
it's very easy to actually dismiss
creative work as a low priority
so how i counted this was to create some
useful resources for them to see
and learn how valuable design can be to
their organization and goals
and what i hope is that as a creative
you know you can even share this with
your non-profit or your client if
they're not convinced
since the months of launching making
meaning
i always try to check in with volunteers
from time to time
and it's been really heartening to
receive messages from them
and find out more about their experience
interestingly
volunteering actually helped many of
them
you know with their mental well-being
during this time
students told me that you know
volunteering gave them confidence
in their skills and the potential to
keep doing good
and professional shared with me that
they felt a renewed sense of purpose
and redirected the anxiety as they could
spend their free time
you know between jobs after work doing
something meaningful
overall the sentiment was that making
meaning left them in a happier place
so after these conversations um i truly
understood the role that
making meaning could play both in
uplifting the design community
and empowering creatives to you know
change the way that they see
their own role and career for the wider
society to truly appreciate design
it has to begin with us valuing our own
skills
and approaching design work with that
same attitude
we're just starting but you know i hope
to eventually cover all sorts of topics
and issues that creators struggle with
you know including work-life balance
imposter syndrome or even what it means
to come out of your comfort zone um when
posting about
project openings or sharing completed
projects
i also make it a point to explain the
real life impact
of the world be getting shares on a
fundraising campaign
or attracting more sign ups for a new
initiative
okay so um to end this
let me just share this uh slide with a
snipper of the works that our creative
volunteers have done so far
it may not look like much but it's part
of a wider growing collective movement
to get the general public
more aware and involved in understanding
participating and helping the community
yeah we hope to keep growing and doing
more so if you're interested in joining
in
please do thank you
thanks so much for for sharing the idea
yeah i just just
wanted to you know just thank you for
sharing all the range of different
projects that
everyone has done i'm sure you would
like to find out more about you know how
it has impacted the
nonprofits directly and how it has
changed the work
over how it has changed you know the
approach moving forward especially
looking for help across different areas
how you know when they're looking for
volunteers it's not just about
how i'm looking for volunteers it's not
just about you know um
soliciting funds but also finding people
you know who have a heart and can blend
all these things together
so um we have a question from someone
but i'll keep all the questions to the
end
of this and also um thank you for some
of the questions so far so they're
really
intense questions and really exciting
ones they'll go through all of them
towards the end of our
our session after this so let me just
move on to the next speaker
bernie and i'm sure many of you have
heard of tape measures
so this is a brilliant visual archive
that documents the charm of everyday
design
in the form of social distancing our
safe distinct markers
all around singapore and i'm sure all
around the world as well
so this is a project you know i would
say it's almost as covet related as
things get
and bernie's going to share with you a
little bit more about this you know how
she collects all these different
wonderful images
and know what it means to i guess all of
us uh as
we go about looking at areas that we
cannot
um you know how we make sense of the of
space right now in public space
thank you okay bernie please hi thanks
daryl
so hi everyone uh i'm bernie i'm an
artist curator and writer and uh i'll be
sharing about my project
tape measures or at t mesh at tape
underscore measures which is
an instagram account that functions um
as a visual record of safe distancing
markers in singapore during the
covet 19 pandemic um
so uh it's focusing particularly on the
use of tape
of course given the name um and i'm
really coming into this not as a
designer as i mentioned just now it's
not
it's not my job description but uh i'm
here as someone who has been documenting
this
phenomenon of this collective vernacular
design
um in the time of one of the the
defining events of the 21st century
so i started this instagram account on a
whim actually on one sunday morning at
the end of march when we were just over
a week
into the initial phase of safe
distancing measures
that were actually visible in public
spaces so at the time i only had three
images in my collection
but the markers were slowly taking over
our city in response to the two main
rules set up by the government which is
do not sit on marked seats and to keep
one meter apart from others which i'm
sure we're all familiar
we're very very familiar with by now
and as you can see from these images
tape was and in fact still
is the most common medium despite the
many other materials we have seen in the
past
few months such as other kinds of
physical barriers
or homemade signs or
custom design stickers
or these paint in this case
plastic sheets or garbage bags or
plastic really
intense plastic wraps or even in this
case
everyday objects where uh the coffee
shop just used the tray to basically
block out all the
tables um and chess
but i mean ultimately again going back
to tape it's
i think it the characteristics of this
medium make it a very logical
choice for the ad hoc creation of safe
distancing markers so
it's easily available it's affordable
versatile
adhesive in some cases removal
removable comes in a variety of bright
colors
doesn't require any skill to to use or
to apply
so some establishments might even have
old rows of tape
lying around you know and they can they
can just like in a moment just do
something like this which is
um an example from from godam the
basement of golden mile
tower uh where they actually used um
this 14 year old tape designed by
theseus chan
uh for the singapore biennale 2006. um
and this is not an art space this is
just you know a regular
um like uh the kind of bukata whatever
thai restaurants in the basement of
golden mao tower
um and actually i spoke to theseus
because of this and
and talked to him about how i i myself
have
like the still have roles of this this
tape from from the
singapore biennale 2006. so
if you think about it um tape as a
medium is actually
this very inconsequential and flimsy
thing i mean you can see from these that
you know very soon just maybe a few
weeks into the circuit breaker they're
all kind of falling apart
um but at the same time it has this kind
of power to physically block off or
regulate movement um as people who live
in a city i think we're all already
quite used to navigating our environment
through these
abstract forms so like the markings on
roads or
already existing use of barricade tape
to signal no entry things like that
so in a sense all of us are equipped
with this basic understanding of how to
communicate through the use of lines
um so what i've observed from collecting
all these photos
is um so it's
quite a few different methods so one of
course is very straightforward single
dividing lines on the floor
to represent the one meter intervals um
use of crosses or diagonals to mark out
where people
shouldn't sit or sand and then boxes or
circles or
you know whatever kind of a space
defining
kind of shape to mark up where people
should sit or stand
um then arrows to show the directions of
the queue
and then this is quite familiar i think
back when
uh we were going to hawker centers to
pick up food but you know they were just
connecting tables
to the edges of seats using tape
and then writing even writing on tape
in these cases and then using tape to
create text or numbers
on the floor um you know in the in the
place of using signs
so you can see i think from from all
these different examples that even
within
same so-called types there isn't always
uniformity and you know they can always
be combined in these endless
permutations such that
you know at the height of of when you're
going out and seeing all these safe
distancing markers
it's almost like every shop or every
coffee shop every every supermarket
every whatever was
like a kind of a different encounter
with this everyday space
so it only grew more intensive uh
as we went into a circuit breaker period
in april during which
public spaces were basically off limits
so this was the period when we were
seeing things like
uh playgrounds and public seating uh
wrapped in the red and white barricade
tape um
and there was this kind of i think a
very over
anxious energy to it and i really think
it couldn't have been achieved
with without tape as this medium and and
this existing familiarity we have with
it
but dialed up to like 100 um and kind of
creating all these patterns and
and and kind of intense
um wrapping and and blocking off
so what was already very interesting
uh and strange that these markings were
appearing all around us to regulate how
we use public space
i think what made it even more
interesting was that beyond the two
rules there was no clear template for
for the act of marketing itself so this
meant that the interpretation of the
rules became the responsibility of
workers who maintain hawker centers and
public parks and hdb estates or
owners and employees of shops businesses
restaurants coffee shops office
buildings
shopping centers etc so um
i think what you could see is really
this this kind of bottom-up
uh uh approach to to
what we would of course like looking at
it would think of as design
so in the absence of any top-down
implementation the onus has been
on these individuals to create and
design the safe distancing markers so
what tape measures is really documenting
is how
people adapt and respond to the measures
in these diverse ways depending on their
individual resources
and approaches to problem solving and of
course even personal preferences
so you know like in the case of these
three they're all
um they're all representing a cue but
manifest in such
completely different ways um so it has
inadvertently
transformed the urban environment into a
series of vernacular graphic
interventions that can be incredibly
diverse and even if we take the case of
a
of a singapore pool's outlet and every
one of them has been issued these little
footprints that say practice social
distancing but um
each one of them kind of manifests in a
different way depending on the
on the person who's kind of implementing
this um
so what would seem on the surface to be
a very basic system
has been completely elevated by all
these subjectivities
and they still have this recognizable
commonality
and it's become this visual language
that can be straightforward
or scary or amusing
or confusing or even iconic and this is
probably i think one of the most well
known and even i
um after circuit breaker ended was went
out to make a pilgrimage to this
uh to starbuster to see this for myself
um so it almost feels like this very
surreal
citywide community driven art project
that captures this
strange time and space that we are all
inhabiting
um and so what i realized really early
on from this project was
these safe distancing markers were
becoming a way of
engaging with and relooking everyday
spaces and
this engagement was spontaneously
occurring among so many people from many
walks of life so
while i started to account for fun i
opened up for submissions from the very
beginning and
invited people to send photos just using
the messaging function on instagram
with the date and location of the image
and one of my first contributors was
actually azalea who was also speaking
today after after me
and being already part of the community
the art design community in singapore i
was
i was not re receiving not just
submissions but kind of
you know having conversations with with
other creatives who are recognizing that
this was this
um unprecedented visual phenomenon that
was happening in our urban environment
um but besides that i've of course also
received a lot of submissions from from
regular people
who could see very clearly that we are
we were and still
are being surrounded by these eggs there
are some mix of creativity and
anxiety and absurdity so here's an
example of a conversation
i had quite early on with someone about
the cultural divide
over the use of the x as a marking so
she said uh she spoke with a canadian
who thought she was supposed to stand on
the x because
um of x marks the spot uh whereas in
singapore i think we're more familiar
with
x as a means to not do something and the
way that you know
we're saying he cannot uh little cannot
bring the durian on the bus stop and
things like that so i think we are used
to
to the x or the the kind of diagonal as
a
um preventative kind of image rather
than
a please stand here kind of image yeah
so over the past seven months i've made
over 1400 posts
uh chosen from a crowdsource archive of
over 2400 images
in addition to amassing my own
collection of about 700
which are all mostly living on my phone
because i don't really have the time to
to kind of archive everything properly
besides my own
my own collection so i've also received
because i got a bit of international
press coverage for i don't know what
how i got i got it but i got it um
so i have over 300 international
submissions
um from definitely more than 30
countries
so which i put these i post in my
instagram stories and
and um kind of try to update it
when i can and when i get submissions so
just some examples here from all over
the world
um including this one that i don't the
one in the middle and rotterdam
um in a cinema i don't know how it
actually helps with
social distancing but i guess they are
definitely having fun with with the tape
so back in april may and june i was
posting about 15 images per day like i
had
reminders on my phone one every hour
from 9am to 11pm
but now as the situation in singapore
has calmed and
the same distancing markers are slowly
disappearing or becoming less
slightly less needed uh post only once a
day
uh receive new submissions only once
every few days
um don't get many likes so i'm just
using it as like an archive
but in a way i would say this is the
kind of project that you hope will die
because the beauty of these
vernacular safe distancing markers is
it's
in their collective effort mayoral
spontaneity
but um and the fact that they are these
impermanent
interventions into permanent spaces but
um i think more importantly we the
disappearance of these markers would
mean that things are going back to some
semblance of normalcy and not just a new
normal but
but a way of life that that you know was
so
taken for granted less than a year ago
so um i'm just like to end this
presentation by saying that
the ability to practice social
distancing is in itself a form of
privilege
and sometimes distancing cannot be
conducted safely or even at all
and even as we're opening up i think the
pandemic will have a long lasting impact
on the most vulnerable in our society
society so just wanted to say to
consider donating to ngos assisting
marginalized communities for whom
distancing isn't always safe
viable or sustainable so home twc too
health serve etc
to support migraine workers and aware to
support victims of domestic violence and
then
the west mutual aid spreadsheet which
you may or may not know about where
people who are falling through the
cracks are actually asking for help
so yeah that's the the end of my
presentation and i end with with cats
so thanks everyone for listening and i
look forward to
to any questions later thanks bernie for
especially drawing um you know
special attention to what is happening
you know
to the different groups of people who
can really be benefiting from
you know some of the work that we do as
i guess as creatives or designers or not
specifically designers
so i think that's a very interesting
question asked by mark that talks about
collaboration between
maybe making meaning and even you know
talking about how
uh we can design perhaps almost a design
guide to
to give some directions for for
different people to
block out different spaces or kind of
explore this idea of
using tape so i i think you know this
this
brings us very interestingly to the
third project you know how perhaps all
of these can combine together and
you know form something that um really
explores you know projects that come out
from this time
that uh that really shows but how you
know how
design can impact the community and how
design can can link different groups of
people together
and i think you know what especially
love for session is how
it talks about you know the basic
communication through lines
so even though you know she's mentioned
she's not a designer i think you know
this project really explains how
design has designs being practiced by
people
with different problems who have to
solve it through you know everyday
solutions whatever they can find
and i and i love all these different
versions of
everyday design so this brings me to the
final project so last but not least we
have this
project called field work so field work
you know it's a series of initiatives
and it's run by judea and azealian
one of the really cool thing about it is
that so both of these are also then
members
so you know we're part of the whole
group that organizes all these different
events and exhibitions
and also that um something that's really
special is how it con
connects all these different communities
through design
so they also took participants on the
virtual tour around red hill
and i was really fortunate to be able to
attend this and i had so much fun just
you know checking out visiting the
different markets
and all different spots around big hill
as they use
as they really use technology such as
you know it felt like this was
this this whole tour which i actually
planned to be done in person
you know was specially made to be done
online so i'll pass the time over to
them
to tell you a little bit more about
their project thank you daryl
while you summarize the project really
well i feel like i don't even i feel
like i can skip my first few slides
already
hey hi everyone thanks for saying to now
my name is julia and together with me is
azila who's on this call as well
as daryl mentioned we are part of the
design associates network
and um so basically ever since last year
um azir and i we developed developed a
curiosity around
how the identity of our neighborhoods
came to be i think there was a question
earlier i saw about someone asking about
local
dogs and myths as well and that's
actually our starting point i'll share a
little bit more later
but yeah so we developed this curiosity
into how the
place identity of our different
neighborhoods came to be so
um being super excited we came together
and we were like okay let's do a project
to
see how we can um kind of use design
to create conversations around place
making in singapore
and um ever since then we came up with a
massive proposal to submit um to get
resources
and it was finally approved after a few
rounds only to be very wonderfully
disrupted by circuit breaker so i don't
know if you can see like hints of it in
the slide but we were supposed to do a
physical
uh field work of um a few tricks and
spatial interventions all around great
hill
because we were very interested to build
on the folk door of ritu
if you don't know that formula upgrade
here i would recommend you to go and
look into it because it's really um
quite mind-blowing
but yeah so um because of circuit
breaker we had to basically
change everything and i think this is
how our project fits into today's
sharing as well you know
in response to kovit um i think one
question that i was really
hit by from the change of events was
uh what would place making actually look
like in times of isolation
so i actually remember scrolling on my
phone at
bernie's tape measures account like
literally looking at all the tapes and
um wondering that wondering how
the fact that it is part of the law to
distance
yourself from your community physically
so if that is part of the law how can we
still bring people together
and how can we still carry out the um
the values of case making to design
even in isolation so i think um that
this question basically brought us to
change everything that we planned so all
the massive proposals that we wrote
would basically
wait and taunt the pieces and we within
three weeks we basically came together
to put together to put a virtual field
trip
on with you because we really wanted to
see how
we could still bring people together in
isolation
so the purpose of this field trip was
not just to talk about the design of
everyday life within the community
but also to uh we wanted to see
i think the nature of it being virtual
uh yeah it allowed us to collaborate
with people from
other domain knowledge and that's why we
collaborated with
myths on a red hill which is a community
arts movement
and my community which i'm sure some of
you might have heard they have been
around for 10 years
and they focus and specialize in
community heritage
um with pacemaking as well so um
just to give you a really quick overview
we took um 130 participants on a virtual
review
uh virtual rehumans virtual trip
to raid hero and um it basically
ranges from different activities myths
myth telling and leave breaking and
basically we took them to three specific
locations
being a way to market the evolving
htv estates around wakefield closed and
lastly enabling village
uh we wanted to okay so this is the
exciting this
this is the exciting part we wanted to
recreate how
um spontaneous the spontaneous
portions of uh our initial proposal
could still play out in a virtual
setting so uh
as part of the virtual field trip we
actually allocated
times for our participants to wander
around google earth and
take the role as a photographer and take
screenshots
about everyday design that they that
they see
through the field trip yeah after the
sharing so i just want to show
and share some of these images with you
these are all taken by our participants
and for one location only which is way
too market
so i basically let them to observe what
was above their eye level so some of
them to
know all these s hooks how people hang
their different condiments especially
because of the
limitation of space within the market we
talked about signages
design type and all the different
numbering systems
even temporary installations like this
chair
then i got them to look at what's at
their natural eye level as well so
that's i guess
what is supposed to attract the customer
or the consumer
and that drew us to the range of
products or services that the market
could offer
the kind of vernacular objects that they
would use to store their um
their goods and and then we also even
brought them to look below the eye level
to look at the ground
how the different materiality of the
ground in our public spaces kind of
firstly takes and guides our movement
throughout the market area
or how the texture of the house makes it
non-sleep especially for the wet market
area
so i think we really wanted to bring the
heart of design
into the community as opposed to getting
them to
enter museums or exhibitions in order to
engage with this kind of content
and um it was really interesting uh
because a lot of the spontaneous
conversations
around design and everyday life came
out of all these images and pictures so
uh
that was really how we designed for
collectivity
amongst the participants this is
actually the different collaborators
that i work with
so i also wanted to see how we could
design for collectivity amongst
collaborators
and basically we are all from different
specializations
azealia representing design and then
we've got izzy and
oh no sorry this is so i mean someone
wrongly
izzy and jetty in the middle who
represents community arts and then the
rest of them are from
my community so i think it's not just
about our different specializations but
also our different experiences
and our different phase of life make it
a very wholesome
collaboration and i think it was a
really humbling experience as well to
take the step out to work with people
from different disciplines
and outside of the creative community
and to be able to see how
it's not just designed and makes a place
but it's actually so multifaceted you
know it's all about the community
stories
about people's experiences it's about
the building of the place
um about the construction of the public
space and
of course the people that listed
themselves and what they have to share
for
so uh i think another part of
collectivity is that we wanted to see
we are sorry we wanted to see how this
project could support uh the creative
community as well
so um during the whole process we tried
as much as we could to involve the
freelance community
in particular but knowing i mean i think
personally for myself knowing that a lot
of them has lost their jobs because of
um covet so we basically um
got different designers photographers
and
different artists to come together and
um with the resources that we were given
we we supported them financially as well
through these works
and i think that um it was really it was
really a
very good experience of how a project
like that could not only involve
the participants the collaborators but
also
involve the creative community that we
are actually a part of
so sorry very quickly the second
question that
hit me was basically this what if such
projects had no end
and i think the driving factor behind
this was that i felt a lot of place
making projects
tend to be quite one-off occurrence or
it could be very touch and go
and i wanted to be sensitive towards
that you know
myself being a designer entering into a
different neighborhood
how can i bring about some form of
continuity
in the projects that we do so this is
under design for continuity and it
frames a lot of the way we
planned out our field work in wiki as
well
so some examples of how the
project continued on was that after our
first round of virtual
field trade we were approached by
artifacts to actually do a second round
that is
more focused on the architecture of the
public spaces
so we were definitely open to that and
it was an another new
main domain of knowledge right so it's
another opportunity for collaboration
and intersections between our different
fields
so we did another round with artifacts
just earlier this october actually so
pretty recent um
and on top of that i think that during
the planning and curation of the project
i uh one thing
okay continuity was a really important
value to me because i wanted to make
something that was
i wanted to create something that would
last and
i felt that yeah i
came to to give you an analogy you know
we don't enter into a neighborhood
um if you want to do placemaking you
don't enter in the neighborhood
put a piece of brick on the ground and
leave but we should enter the
neighborhood and look for an
existing structure and build on
what is what someone else is already
building so that it's like
a it's a collective effort and it builds
collectively together to be something
bigger so i think that it was very
intentional for me to
reach out to my community and miss on
the radio and sprout heart because they
are um
existing initiatives that have already
been
working within the philadelphia hero and
i wanted to ausley and i wanted to see
how
a design perspective in collaboration
with whatever they had to offer could
come together
to bring a more holistic flavor and to
activate you know civic engagement
within within the place
so i felt like this was really important
and so even now
we actually documented
the whole virtual future experience into
the book
because he wanted to materialize the
event and
um share it back to the community share
it back to the community
and this book is currently available at
my communities museum
and miss on the radio and also sprouts
her upcoming library
so i'll pass my time over to azir now
who will tell you a little bit more
about how
the few notes came about and and how you
can be
a part of it as well so as we are
offered to you okay
so building on uh to what julia have
said
uh so few notes is really actually the
embodiment of the digital toe in a
physical
format as well and it's the reason so is
really the nature of how we wanted
this whole field work to not be a
one-off i think a lot of times
when it comes to design education on
things it's a rare touch and go and it
doesn't build on
so this book was created with that in
mind so the content that you see in the
book is generated by the participants
themselves
and you know this book in itself is
seeded back into the community
for them to for for this um digital tour
to actually
be ongoing and it's really something
that just doesn't just stop there after
the tournament itself so moving on to
the next slide these are some of the
spreads that were being designed
um so we we made it a point to actually
um
have relevance to the digital space um
with the link to how the spreads were
even being designed
uh because in the workshop that we are
doing
we are actually also going educating the
general public what book design is about
um what you know they
the process in making a book and also um
you know
what do we see or what do we think of as
designers when we actually touch um
uh i mean when we design the things the
medium that we're working with
uh so um yep next slide um
yeah so overall right uh we tried to
keep things
as exciting as possible um because
obviously it's in a printed format so
uh one of the interesting insights that
happened during the trip was because we
used a google slide in our first time
uh and someone actually deleted the host
like halfway through the the trip and it
was really panicky so the spread that
you see on the left it's really
you know how the conversation of the
chat box was was like oh my gosh the
site is gone like
you know uh how is it coming back and
then we have thankfully like someone was
uh one of the i think the participant
was like oh why don't that's all just
control z together
and then it's like oh it came back up so
in
essence that was a bit of a we were
separate but then it was like oh problem
solving together as well
and then also these are photos that's
what judea said um
were images that were taken by the
participants so it's an immersive
experience made accessible to all now
those who weren't actually on the trip
so we actually had a workshop that we
are doing now we are running it uh
co-currently so there's one this coming
weekend and there's another one
the following weekend uh where we
actually um talk about
um um yeah i mentioned earlier book
design and things like that
and also it's the whole nature of
actually with now that you know
um coverage situation is easing out i
mean we did take uh
precautions uh to the event as well but
i think slowly we also wanted like the
in-person contact uh
for the workshops so this is really us
going out into the community yeah
i'm sorry next um so book as a
conversation started beyond the
community was something that
i think uh really
i would never expected um this to come
out from the project but i think
recently
uh i got an email from a participant so
uh we actually sent out the books the
participants who were on the first trip
and then uh you know he got back an
email and saying like well this book is
really like
the virtual experience and he actually
started asking me like i wonder how a
non-participant will experience this
book
and he plans to pass this book around to
a few of his friends to find out
and interestingly i think um he this
person actually isn't really a designer
but he also
um you know was curious about what's the
process beside
behind boat making and he actually
listed the different bullet points as
you've seen so i was just
i was actually pretty impressed like wow
he actually thought through the whole
process
and in fact it was i think phil knows
has really
um carried the heart of what we wanted
to do which is
something that's uh would continue to
seed out
that that's that continuity um with the
whole initiative that we're trying to do
and uh this guy
he is also a person who actually leads
um tangling
trail and then you know i mean the last
sentence that 30 overtimes in five years
and i'm now curious about how
this would look like uh in a book format
as well so
in a sense whereby just a few notes like
this that you know
um we wanted to do actually has maybe
ripple effects of actually provoking um
people's thoughts on how things are
being made
and it's really what the conversation is
about
and then we i replied back saying like
okay we are excited uh let us know your
feedback and mainly it's like you know
if he ever does a tangling tour like i
mean i i believe we are more than happy
to actually attend it
and also this is how i think you know we
are really trying to link and preach
things that you know you know if he
really wants
his book or like uh you know tangling uh
troll to
be designed into a book um you know we
are open to collaborations and i think
this is how you know you see that
there's slowly like you know
intersecting of like the the general
public and design as well
just with something that you know uh of
a pure good intention and it's it's
seeded out in that sense so uh moving on
okay even with the workshops right
we have like diverse uh when i mean
diversity i really mean diverse like
participants so there was a mother
daughter who actually owns a farm
uh an urban farm so we held the
workshops at uh city sprouts it was one
of the
locations in the trip as well so you can
see that we
are very intentional about everything
everything is actually intertwined even
with um
what the content was uh shown in the
workshop as well
so the mother and daughter did urban
farming and surprisingly she wasn't on a
trip so everyone here wasn't
participants on the trip and she flipped
through the back of the boat and she
raised like oh her daughter's face is in
the book because
one of our collaborators who runs the uh
the
city sprouts shed the photos and she was
like you know pleasantly surprised we
have people from a.i
uh and uh industries we have people who
are actually mba students and
design students as well but i think the
most interesting thing was there's
actually also
a book publisher who um was in the
session as well and we ended up actually
conversing after the event
with everyone together it wasn't just me
and her but really just
the general community just conversing in
like what this whole
book publishing is uh what the
initiative brought about independent
publishing
and things like that so moving on i
think um you know
it was really nice to hear different
stories especially with the mother and
daughter as well
i think um you know they shared their
thoughts and understanding of what the
place was
so the rest of the participant has never
been to city sprouts
so it was really just a very nice
community
uh initiative because after we did a
workshop she was like hey guys do you
guys want to come
to go to my like on farm it's just
across um
the car park so a city sports setting is
in a school
uh building so this is the canteen and
opposite uh it's literally where across
the field is the
farming stuff and it just became very
organic that uh
connections were being built and things
like that so i think
uh the book in itself this book uh
per se or what we have like got out of
it or learned from it is that it's like
a lot lifelong education
um for the community and also previously
how it's a conversation starter
so a lifelong education in a community
what do i mean by that i think
there's always that gap uh with
designers or even the general public or
like you know sometimes
i'm pretty sure uh designers would know
that your parents will
not know what you're doing how are you
doing kind of thing but
this is really where we actually educate
the public on
the behind the scenes of how a book
comes to be it's not just like what you
see in the stores but we i actually
shared the process like the design in
terms of anatomy of the boat
to actually offset printing which is
something that you know i don't think uh
the general public knows and it's good
that
uh you know these are seeded into the
community
uh and also um things like distribution
so we actually also learned through
making the book uh
uh with uh we used vernacular objects
but there was one a simple activity
because uh
obviously with barriers and stuff won't
do too complex we took the
core binding and then we just turned
turn into a book so that it's
not uh not too liberally intensive but
what was
important here was that like whatever
that's inaccessible is made accessible
here
so like you know we brought like the
printing plates from the uh
the actual printing plates from the
print uh the book that we did
uh to share with the people there like
okay this is what a plate look like
um you know the quality of how the print
is uh
and you know from then on you actually
brew this like appreciation to
actually things that they actually take
for granted like such as
just a book on a table next up is we use
um everyday object to
make it uh to make the book because i
think the whole gist on this was
actually
um educating books
um educating on books with books in in
sense
um and also like really you know
everyday objects in itself helps to
demystify i think also um a lot of times
you would think like oh making or
binding a book or crafting a book is
like
it's very technical you need to know
like software's like oh in design or
something but actually sometimes
just your day-to-day items you can
actually make something with it as well
um so uh the next slide so this is um i
think it was one of the participants who
actually made the book
and i think she shared it on social
media and stuff but in essence i i think
with the use of
vernacular objects as well is really our
means to actually try to
have as is like an entry point it's like
a relevance to people and that they
won't feel
uh intimidated with trying things
because these are things they see
uh in their day-to-day so i think
yeah that's mainly about it uh so lastly
okay uh we talked so much about the book
i have the physical book here
it's really nicely designed so
i think the designer of the book is
actually in this call right now
just shouting out to her thanks for the
hard work together
um but you can get a copy just take your
phone screenshot the
uh qr code and then you'll be sent to a
google link form fill out the details
uh we are doing our best to make
send it out as soon as possible um and
also
um if you want it fast you can actually
get it
at ndc so when you enter the building in
itself right
uh at the front counter already there's
the book there you you can't run from it
it's really bright weight
and then uh if you know you don't really
see it there you can go up to
the place where they are shared earlier
which is um level five of ndc building
and that's where dan studio is and this
is actually outside dance studio
uh it's quite a cozy place it's an open
place as well i don't think a lot of
people
know about it but you know there's
charging points and a very nice like
table and stuff so
you know you can actually just go there
and drop by and chill for
um whatever real reason and if anyone's
in the studio
i'll feel free to pop by and just like
you know have a conversation
with any of us so uh i'll end this as
well um
next slide uh thank you and also if
you know if you guys are up for like
collaborations
or anything like that uh email us at
dsga.net gmail.com
or if you have any suggestion with like
neighborhood tours or trips and stuff
like that or
you have feedback for us just uh
redirect there to the email and
we'll get back to you as well so um
thank you for
staying with us and listening
thank you so much so thanks for sharing
so much about a few work i think you
know the only pretty is that so many
people here wish they had the chance to
attend it i wish they you know could
just pop by for the different sessions
and all that so i think you know it's
great that we you have the online
portion of it and there's also something
that's in person so you know i guess
participants do get to experience both
of it
and so um what's going to happen after
this is that we're going to a
random question answer so there have
been quite a few questions already
and uh what i'll be focusing on are the
questions that are
pertaining to the projects directly so
some about i guess the design industry
on the whole but
we'll just be focusing on questions that
are you know about these
projects and if they're any more along
the way that pop up you want some
clarification
please continue asking them so you know
just listening to all these different
projects so far you know what what
really strikes me is that it's all very
community focused
so you know in making meaning it's
almost like you're creating a new one by
building bridges between nonprofits and
also the different designers
different kind of like isolated
communities that are brought together by
design
and the second one is you know about
well for tape measures we talk about
drawing ideas and contributions from the
community
so even something that's a bit ironic
right in a time when we are so isolated
when talking about being a part
uh how all these things actually connect
all these kind of
connect all of us together and also for
field work
you know we're talking about stepping
into a community and how these
stories and myths are the things that
connect all of us you know back you know
from a shared history to
you know a story a narrative that's
going on
through all the different organizations
and spaces so
i think that the first question i want
to ask all of you
is but okay it's very anonymous
but okay we don't know the name but you
know um
so as as working designers so i guess as
working creatives you know have you seen
any changes in terms of how
your work scope has has um shifted a
little bit during this pandemic
and especially you know we'd love to
hear a bit more in the context of your
project so has that been something that
um because of the project perhaps how
it's pivoted digitally
how this has contributed to the way you
work normally or maybe
even some things that you have changed
and how it's benefited
the projects so um yeah any of you can
can start offers um okay
i'll go first so i think
that's definitely um i think the
challenges that you know so i work in a
brand consultancy
so i think the challenges that brands
face now are really evolving from what
they were pre pandemic
and so their priorities will definitely
change as well
so in response to these needs my scope
as a designer has also changed
um we've been experimenting a lot with
you know things like online workshops
and also shifting our focus to
brand building in a predominantly
digital world
we're also focusing less on visual
design you know because a lot of
clients have cut their budgets and are
working more on strategic stuff that
actually helps them
pivot and stand out in this new normal
thank you and any anything you might
want to add based on you know
even the having worked on making meaning
has it
is that is there anything you might want
to connect or any add to it
um in terms of scope change before this
whole thing
um i wasn't even working on making
meaning so
great thanks so much which change from
nothing to something big
bernie would you like to go next
it's not affecting my workflow because a
design workflow doesn't exist in my life
um i think that we shared a bit of it
earlier as well
um i think echoing what danielle said
one thing that we at least i really
realized is that
design is actually a very non-visual
practice
as much as it is visual so i think um
azi and i kind of we didn't really know
what to label ourselves when you asked
us to
write a short bio so we called ourselves
creative facilitators
because we felt like a lot of the work
of designers is facilitating people's
thoughts of facilitating what people
want to look at or
interface with and i think that that's
actually a key part of our role
um that has been made even more so
during this period
it's really about like how our project
frames the way people look at
everyday life now um after these strange
times you know or
yeah how does how do what we do or what
we curate um affect the way people think
and look at things okay so i think that
refrains my perspective a bit
well speaking of what to call ourselves
i didn't really want to call myself
after this but
but i also felt i went through a lot of
different words for like
okay like what to call myself like i was
like creator
i just felt so weird like so god like
and
i mean existential crisis tape measures
can't exist without all the people that
submitted to it and
all the like people that made these kind
of
interventions in the world so i think if
i had to say something about that it's
that
it's the maybe you know is this very
simplified and very idealistic but it's
a kind of like a democratization
of design because you need i mean
it's not like everybody can go and ask a
designer go and design their safe
distancing of course now nowadays now
you you can walk into a
a cafe or a bubble tea or whatever and
they have their custom-made
designs but at the time right it's just
like we have to respond
in 24 hours and this is how we respond
so i think
like understanding that that you don't
have to be
a designer to design in that
in that way like in a way that needs a
need
and an immediate need
yeah i think it's always a bit tricky
when you know we have to put a word
behind our name especially when you're
limiting it's just one thing right so
one one thing that we've heard today you
know for example to know sharing how
uh you know you move into almost kind of
putting yourself at
the point of from the point of view of
an educator because you know how many
things are you going to add together and
you know especially for example the role
of field work how many roles have you
played just
kind of putting all these different
things together so i think uh you know
maybe for the
benefit of just everyone here but also
you know thanks for sharing the
the train of thought behind this if you
ask me to put i
yeah many times you know it's almost as
if you know we play very
very many different roles and especially
since uh i mean
the nature of our work is changing i'm
sure we're gonna add a few more to this
list
so um okay i've got two questions for
bernie right now so the first one is you
know what's your favorite
okay so uh someone asked what's your
favorite tape measure of everything that
you've documented so far
so i think even better if it might have
been one of those that you know you
showed them you can put yeah
and then sorry uh second question i'll
just ask both so you can
see how yeah you wanna answer that and
the second one is also you know is there
a chance that
uh there's going to be an exhibition
featuring all these things
and i suppose it's also a bit uh
interesting because you know we're
talking about this and keeping ourselves
apart and exhibition
will actually bring everyone together so
any thoughts about that and
you know even what form it might take
okay
uh well let me just share my screen
again
so uh
i'll give the boring answer which is
that every tape measure is special
in its own way
[Laughter]
but okay i mean some of the ones i guess
the this chicken one um
[Music]
that was really interesting i mean
there's some way where i get it in my
inbox
and i'm like oh my god there's um you
know something i've never seen before
and i think the chicken one was was part
of it which was it was from this coffee
shop in barcelona's where it was just it
wasn't just chicken now it was also like
the coffee shop had their own
the same similar style with a painting
and then said kopi
instead of chicken in chinese and a
chicken
painting um i think the ones that really
show like like it's just like a logic
that i would never have thought of so
like this this chair
thing this kind of like accidental
like installation sculpture thing or
this um
or this this then when when they kind of
solve
a problem in a way that you know you
don't really need to go that far like
the
this one or the right and um
i think that's those are like the kind
of like interesting ones or something
like this where
where um you're not actually
doing anything by stopping you're not
stopping anybody from from sitting on
this thing
um by wrapping it with this tape you
know but but at the same time
it's able to to send that signal
and i mean singaporeans are more more or
less quite obedient people so
so i think they see this and they're
like okay i know i can't
do that um yeah so
um yeah there's
of course the and whenever i get a cat
one it's nice
to see that oh and um i think this one
which is one of my own finds the one in
in mokyo it was in a bakery
um and i think just the
why did they choose to do a blue and red
arrow they run out of tape like it's
like you know the kind so you go
when you see it and you're like there's
some kind of strange
story behind this or strange logic
behind this that
that can only happen because this
particular person made it
i think those are probably the most most
interesting
okay so in terms of the um
the the afterlife of tape measures
i think back when i started this i was
like super excited i'm gonna build a
website
i'm going to have a have a
publish a book and i even got in touch
with a designer
i was like yes i would do it um although
i did this very silly thing at the start
which was
i because i was like i just let people
do the most convenient thing which is to
dm me their photos
so all the photos are like a bit crappy
because they have been pixelated by
instagrams
whatever algorithm that they use to send
images
um which i kind of it's kind of like
okay that's that's part of the the charm
of this aesthetic and it's an instagram
project and i deliberately made my
slideshow out of
um off of screenshots from
from the instagram rather than trying to
get the putting in the original images
and then writing out the captions and
stuff
um but i've been swamped by other things
it's like i mean i'm like a single
person running tape measures
so it's it's been a lot uh i am
trying to work something out in terms of
uh
hosting the at least parts of the
collection
on on an archive some piggybacking on
somebody else's website
um but we still haven't i haven't
confirmed anything
yet besides the intent to do it um and
then the other thing that i've done
is i donated my own collection to the
national library
so they i have been collecting images
relating to the pandemic the documenting
kovite 19 project
so essentially i just sent them um
um the at the time like i don't know 600
images or something that i had of
500 plus with all the captions like
where i took it and what day i took it
um and then the agreements that they
they will let me know if they use it for
any exhibition but they can
they will um i just gave it to them to
use for free love basically
um i mean of course they cannot profit
of it and stuff like that but
i hope but um
yeah and then i think it's a few of my
pictures are going to be in a
in a show at national museum or already
are in a show a national medium but just
like a a web a kind of like a media
interactive thing
so yeah i mean hopefully one day um
i'll be able to create some kind of uh
project that's summing it up but right
now all i'm doing is just posting one a
day
um and and just letting it kind of
uh live in that in that formula
yeah wonderful thanks so much and
i guess if any of you who are in the
audience you don't want to
um assist bernie in her
in her efforts to bring bring her to
life in some capacity i'm sure she would
uh she would love to hear from you and
okay so i'm just gonna move on to the
next few questions so further now i've
got uh i'll just kind of combine the
questions also so
you know what's the response from the
non-profits like so far so you know have
they
um have you heard back directly and you
know you talked about educating them
right so
what's the response to this element of
education from even designers you know
now that they find out you know how to
better
um how to better offer their work in
that sense on a pro bono basis
and you know you also share some of the
considerations right the the negative
feedback
so how you know maybe would love to hear
a little bit more about
that front so how education has
basically benefited both sides
okay thanks for asking the question so i
guess
on the non-profit's response i should
definitely have included their responses
it somehow slipped my mind to include it
but the response was actually very very
good
um most of them were actually very
thankful to find out that this platform
exists
as many of them actually have very lean
budgets which means that they usually
don't spend on design
so they will do it in-house like on
powerpoint
you know like something very low-fi just
to really
get the job done um so when i followed
up with them it was actually very nice
to see that
many of them were actually able to
articulate how the work helped them um
and many of the non-profits were
actually very small community ground-ups
like making meaning who are just doing
good in their spare time so
um a lot of very nice collaborative work
actually came out from that la
so they were actually able to you know
share about how
they really enjoyed working with the
designers and also you know
really learning about the design process
at the same time
yeah um as for the thing about the
negative feedback
interestingly uh although it was a very
big worry of mine when i started this
whole project
none of my peers actually brought it up
um
yeah so but like what i mentioned one of
this was actually like one of the main
considerations i had when i started it
so we actually had a lot of discussion
over for example um
what you know do we ban certain
non-profits if
they have big budgets like if they are
rich
non-profits who have a lot of funding
you know how do we
choose who gets help and who doesn't so
the answer to that question was that you
can't
really pick and choose so what we did
was
um because we didn't want to lower the
cost benchmark for the industry as a
whole was that
we actually kept the number of hours
each project can be worth
so for example things like posters or an
edm or like very simple work
can actually be done pro bono but for
projects that are very long
so like month-long projects so things
like maybe a very long annual report
or a major branding project we actually
advise that
non-profit should we enumerate creatives
with
a token you know 10 to 20 percent of the
project value
and so a good practice is to share the
non-profit
a quote of the full value of your
services provided
and then make it out as a donation to
the organization
so that they actually understand how
much this work is worth
so for example if i do a logo for you
you know then
i can make it out as a donation of i
don't know however much
you feel your work is one of them
um yeah so it's really not about
devaluing
um the design at all
uh it's more about them really knowing
what the value of it actually is
yeah because i feel that um without
making meaning a lot of the non-profits
actually find
work through here they don't even
i mean they would just not hire a
designer at all yeah so
that's what we found so far
yeah that's a good question
thank you so much so i guess um you know
it's it's
like especially when we're dealing with
some clients you know who want to use
design for the first time
it's always the case where you know i
i've always thought about doing this
don't know how to
start you know what's the first stage so
i think you know that guide is is
wonderful you know it
it shows it really kind of answers the
very basic questions that you feel like
oh no i shouldn't be asking these kind
of things
and then it puts it out there and you
know instead of always hiding behind
this
uh this state where we're just a bit
afraid or a bit
kind of embarrassed to ask certain
things now this is there and also for
designers you know you might not even
have thought about approaching
let's say non-profit organizations and
now it provides this
platform so thank you so much for you
know creating this this for
i guess both for designers and also for
non-profits and i guess the the rest of
us who do get to benefit when we see the
wonderful work coming out
okay so i'll move on to field work right
now
so i've got a few questions so the first
one is you know
you know after pivoting digitally right
so
you shared all so much about all the the
hard work that's gone in
before it says just put aside so you
know what are some of the biggest
challenges that you face you know maybe
apart from the stuff getting deleted
what else
you know in the preparation after that
point and also you know
now now that um your term is so creative
facilitators right has it been something
that you know
uh has always been in the back of your
mind or did it kind of like
crystallize just because of your current
role in this project
and yeah so how did you come to this
understanding realization and you know
like
where do you see this going you know is
this a role that you're going to be
taking on or is it just going to
transition to something else also as you
explore the rest of the project
you're going to go ahead okay uh okay
i think for myself uh
with regards to the biggest challenge in
putting
um the field trip together especially
virtually was
um i think
there's the aspect of also cause like we
uh we have full-time jobs right and then
i actually honestly with the initiative
of danielle with
making meaning and bernie also with uh
the tape measures right
it actually really takes a lot of um
there's some for willpower to drive
through this
whole process uh especially when you're
juggling between like
um your day-to-day work which sometimes
can get stressful or so
but i think what kept i guess everyone
else going was you know the want to
actually see
something grow uh you know a good
initiative as well
but the the day job it was really quite
challenging so
i think as jules mentioned earlier we
kind of streamlined the whole virtual
trips
in three weeks and it was a constant
almost
every day a skype call till like
4 30 a.m and then we killed the next day
go to her god
i think it was the one day i was like we
we had a
incident for like the transition to like
in few notes it was like it came like
what
you know we were trying to streamline
everything and then we had a hiccup
in the middle of like oh we need to
cross check to certain external
collaborators as well
and then we was like oh we have no
choice but to push back the deadline and
then we were like
we're so glad we pushed back the
deadline because there was like previous
phase
yeah in in that sense um and then
another one for me was more of that i
think
naturally i'm not as comfortable or
um i'm open to collaborations
but i'm i i have a bit of a high barrier
like i think it's easier for me to
collaborate with someone
uh if i know that person personally or
so but i think this
project in itself challenged me on that
in that sense which
put me a bit up outside my comfort zone
which
i guess it was difficult but i think the
ends of it was actually
quite it was not bad i think it it kind
of does
encourage me to be more open to
collaboration
for myself i think very quickly i think
the thing that i
felt i struggled with most was the
uncertainty
which is uh i think part of your
program names no i think that the nature
of like participate
participatory projects or even place
making projects
where you involve like a large group of
the public of participants is that
there's
a huge room of uncertainty because you
don't really know what
they would contribute you don't really
know how they would respond
and um i think that um
the projects that maybe i'm more
familiar with in the field of design
are very controlled within a very
controlled setting
but i think i feel like this
there's a greater value especially
during this time placed
on co-design with
the community and uncertainty is
definitely a huge part of that
so i think it's learning how to navigate
through that learning how to be okay
with that
and then learning how to think on your
feet and they respond when
when they are unexpected things happen
because of those uncertainties
that would be for the challenges
question
further to quickly address the other
question as well regarding the creative
facilitators
uh i think that the coin coin the term
only when daryl asks us to label
ourselves
but prior to that i feel that i've
always
um saw design as a very uh
as it's very non-visual as much as is
visual that's why
like i think i mentioned earlier i know
when our parents ask us what do we do in
school
and what do we do at work and they
assume it's all drawing
and um and we really can't explain to
them that it's not and
you know the visual aspect is it's
important but
it's actually very very strategic and
planning as well
so i think that's always kind of
ingrained in
in the way i work but we call on that
term
under pressure
i shouldn't have asked you guys you know
to give a little
description but i think it's a great
exercise right it makes us think about
you know how we how we choose to present
ourselves especially when you want to
talk about your project you know what's
an easy way
because if a friend is going to ask you
how do you define yourself to the this
third person you know it always helps if
there's something to kind of at least
anchor some meaning too so okay i think
uh okay i think just the shortest amount
of time left
and it's a final question i think it's
perfect for rounding things up
so uh the the question is you know
for and right now during this kind of
doing these times uh any advice on
skills for others planning to put forth
passion projects
so you know any any tips for anyone who
wants to start their own or who
is really started but maybe it's losing
motivation so maybe just a really quick
uh short piece of advice that you might
have for our audience out here
so i think um my piece of advice is that
you know you're going to create
something or start something you should
just go for it
just try you know don't sit around and
wait for it to slowly happen
um you should just just be determined
and you know for example for myself
i've always had a fear of like
networking or like reaching out to new
people
and in the course of making meaning you
know when i started it nobody knew about
it
i actually had to reach out to like
hundreds
of non-profits and hundreds of designers
you know just to let them know that this
thing exists
because um i mean without letting them
know then
they can't use the platform and then
yeah so
yeah i think you should just go for it
like there isn't really any particular
skills that you know you really need to
have
i think yeah
thank you bernie anything to add that
sorry i'm responding to the question
okay let's go to it
okay um actually i think that the advice
that i would share is to
find a support system around you i think
passion projects are amazing because
um passion
can be more it can be a stronger driver
than money sometimes
as even though it's a good competitor
but i think it's very important to learn
how to take care of yourself when you
are
making time for these side projects as
well so i think finding your support
system and finding that balance is
important
easy oh sorry it's like
thinking uh actually to be honest for me
the first thing that came up to me was
actually what danielle said as well
because i think me and jules has been
talking
about field work actually way before as
well as
i mean during the period of like doing a
proposal and stuff and then
we honestly doubted that it was kind of
gonna happen like is it gonna happen
like we
we revised like five six times like not
too sure if it's gonna happen you know
and then i think
kovit came and because kobe came and it
was just like if we just got to do
something then we
literally it started not thinking that
it would grow that big
that there's collaborators coming in as
well we just started off with like just
a google slide and like okay maybe this
is what
you know the the participants can do and
stuff but along the way
um as you start thinking about the
project naturally i think
you you you pivot and think of
how what can you do to actually make it
more wholesome
and that's when you know when you are in
it already it will just naturally start
growing
yeah and yeah
thank you and bernie oh yes yeah i'm
ready
i feel like i i mean personally i just
kind of fell in
literally fell into tape measures
because i was just like
oh let me just start instagram they'll
be funny and then and then it exploded
this thing that that i got really
obsessive about that i had like all
these reminders on my phone to like tell
me i have to post now post now post now
i know
it cracks all my track of my likes and
stuff like that um
so i mean sometimes these things
they just happen um
because you see something interesting
and then it grows into something bigger
you know and i mean some sometimes you
see all those interesting things and
they never grow into big
things but but you kind of never know
um what will will happen out of it and
if i hadn't
you know if i hadn't created tape
measures i think i mean someone else
would have come along i mean there were
other people
who were trying to document but they
they weren't as intense as
i was so they kind of gave up
um yeah so i think uh
uh you know i mean i'm an artist so
so i'm familiar with this idea like you
are
you pursue these things that may not
have value to
to to anybody else you know i mean
at the point in time when you're
creating it i mean i'm like these are
all my
embroideries and stuff that i make
and i sew and and that i do it because
i feel like i need to as an artist and
that's the way that i'm i'm
kind of putting myself out into the
world um
so so yeah i mean
i don't because i don't see these kinds
of projects
as as means to an end or something it's
just like something that you have to
you feel like you have to do in that
moment and then you you do it and
maybe that moment takes a year like some
of these projects that i do
so i think about them for like one year
then i do it but at the same time it's
like
you know being conscious of those seeds
that you are planting your own
home brain yeah well i'm playing
here sorry
measures was like a seed that i planted
and then it went in
like in 15 minutes i made the instagram
account so
so that's different because i think
before
i knew bernie was the holder of the
account right
i was actually thinking about it at home
as well and then i think someone said me
like hey someone is doing this tape
measure thing i got really excited so i
was like oh my gosh i started asking
people around me like do you have tape
measures and then you should send it to
this account
that kind of thing yeah it was it's
really good that it's after yeah
i mean it's actually very exciting yeah
yeah so i guess to summarize i mean what
what the
what all wonderful partners i've shared
is that you know when you see something
that just go ahead and do it because
there won't be a better time or you know
if you know that somebody else might
also kind of jump in so also the idea
that you know um being open to all these
opportunities when
when for things to happen you know if
you find that's
where there's a nonprofit you know who's
looking for a certain uh
collaboration or you know other kind of
observations that you find based on
what's all around or even just something
that's been hovering in your head for
the longest time you know just to go
ahead
and and go for it and then also you know
be aware of the
support the support system so people
that you need to that might be able to
help you along the way or
those that you can consult or you know
even those that you can collaborate with
to make all these
projects come to life so uh yeah so
thank you so much for joining me on this
thursday evening so just
just before we leave so um yeah
i always feel that you know when things
are messy it's almost like you know
you've got this
big pot of lots of stuff uh just kind of
in a pot if you shake it and shake it
and shake it
okay you never know what you're gonna
come up with and i think you know these
are some of the three
best projects that have uh resulted from
from this pandemic
and you know i'm so glad that we have
them to
share with us today and i'm sure you
have enjoyed it as much as i have
and so before you leave you know we
appreciate if you can just take a little
bit of time to share your feedback on
this session
through a quick survey so i'm going to
pull up the
slide with the qr code there so you can
either scan that or there's also going
to be the link in the chat
so if you want to find out a little bit
more about the programs at the national
design center that we have lined up
for the rest of november under the
next-gen theme which is you know
what we're speaking about right now so
young designers who are going on making
some
wonderful young creatives who are making
wonderful projects
so just scan the qr code and let me just
pull it up or just click the link over
there
so yeah that brings me to the annotation
so please yeah just
let us know about what you you think
about this session and also
you know scan the other one to find out
a bit more about the different programs
so thank you so much for sharing this uh
thursday evening with us
and we hope to see you soon at some of
the you know future events future
programs
and hopefully in person as well so uh be
sure me thanking the
the pandas over here and goodbye to
everyone
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you have a
good night
good night everyone
you